-Okay, Nikki, it is your turn.
-Okay.
-Pull the mic.
Let's see what you got.
-Nikki, Nikki, Nikki!
-Come on.
-Try it, Nikki.
[ Beeping ]
-Musical Genre Challenge!
-Okay!
-♪ Musical Genre Challenge ♪
-Alright, here's how this works.
You're going to get
a song title
and a totally different
musical genre.
Then you have to sing
that song in that style.
Let's see what you get.
-Okay.
-Whoo.
[ Beeping ]
-Please. "Fireworks."
-"U Can't Touch This"...
-Okay.
-...with a girl...
-I can be that.
I don't know if I can be that.
-That's an interesting genre.
Girl with an acoustic guitar
on a college quad.
Do you play the guitar?
-A little bit. A little bit.
-You do?
-Yeah.
-Do you want to play a real one?
-Sure. Yeah, I'll try.
-Hey, do you have one?
-Oh, my gosh.
-You got it.
-This is kind of my dream.
-Thanks, bro.
-Guitar -- Guitar carrier!
-Already?
-Do you need a pick?
-No, I'm just going to strum,
like, you know,
I just got out of class.
I don't have my pick with me.
I'm on campus.
-This is fantastic.
I didn't even know you played.
-I just started a year
and a half ago,
so don't expect much.
-Alright, take center stage.
-Okay.
-Whoo!
-Nikki Glaser.
-Come on, Nikki!
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mellow synth music playing ]
Oh, hey, professor.
[ Laughter ]
-One, two, three!
-♪ My music hits me so hard ♪
♪ Makes me say "Oh, my Lord ♪
♪ Thank you for blessing me ♪
♪♪
♪ With a mind to rhyme
and two hyped feet" ♪
♪ It feels good
when you know you're down ♪
♪ A super dope homeboy
from the Oaktown ♪
♪♪
♪ And I'm known as such ♪
♪ And this is a beat
that you can't touch ♪
♪ I told you, homeboy ♪
♪ You can't touch this ♪
-So good!
-♪ That's how we livin',
and you can't touch this ♪
♪ Look in my eyes ♪
♪ You can't touch this ♪
♪ Yo, let me bust
the funky lyrics ♪
♪ You can't touch this ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Oh, no, you know,
you know you can't touch this ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you!
I'll see you in class!
-Nikki Glaser!
Nikki Glaser, come on!
-Whoo!
-That was a performance!
-Thank you!
-That is how you do it
right there!
-Thank you!
-Oh, my God. Nikki's good.
-You got this.
Thank you, guys!
-Nikki Glaser!